can you tell us what it was like on the
second you give us some idea I think all
of you think we're just rolling on the
floor laughing it's true Jean was the
only one who was laughing and we do 5 6
7 takes 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 takes and
he especially thought she saying she was
the one who broke up and killed everyday
he was he killed every take and nothing
was done about it
gene was a star you know you got to work
quietly around the stuff garsh mar well
anyway here we are on the 15th take when
I say stay close to the candles they're
not only gene laughs but the crew would
laugh a lot I went out and I said get a
thousand dollars to my assistant
director I said get a thousand dollars
to go out and take the money and buy
white handkerchiefs with the thousand
dollars he said say that again
I told him to take the get a thousand
from somebody you know from Fox go out
and buy the white the white hang I'm
sorry Jim gianopolous to say get the
money from Fox by the way he came back
without without ten thousand white
handkerchiefs I gave everybody in the
cast everybody in the crew I'm not in
the cast because in the cassie's no no I
guess that we got a white house but they
were like they were like you know 30
people 40 people in the crew every one
of them got a white handkerchief more
than one white handkerchief and then in
the scene I mean it did be some scenes
where one of the scenes was stay close
to the candles the staircase and she
took a [ __ ] hour
steak stay close to the candles the
staircase can be treacherous some and
then they can't be treacherous the crew
went but you know but I turned around
because we took get the white and it was
a sea of white handkerchiefs I said I
got a hit here yeah
and it was it was you know it's a great
idea in my part because the crew kept
breaking up and laughing at everything
we did it was gene gene on stage now
there anyway anyway well on the
fifteenth take Mel came back and he gave
me a line reading the only one he ever
gave me
and it was perfect I was saying stay
close to the candles the staircase can
be treacherous the line reading he gave
me was stay close to the candles the
staircase can be treacherous that means
we've lost a couple of people what kind
of direction did you give Peter Boyle
what did you tell her later quiet don't
move you know you know it was very
difficult because I said to Peter is it
possible for you to be still and yet
menacing can you do that and he did it
by shifting his eyes from side to side
it was brilliant really brilliant acting
anybody can do I told him not to bring
her hahahaha I knew she'd be trouble